breaking developments now in the case of
Shelley Luthor the Dallas salon owner
who was jailed for reopening her
business despite coronavirus
restrictions Texas governor Greg Abbott
has modified his orders to eliminate
confinement as punishment effectively
freeing Shelley Luthor State Attorney
General Ken Paxton tweeted this the
Supreme Court of Texas has ordered
Shelley Luthor to be released from
Dallas County Jail exclamation point
all this amid the outrage that was
growing over a judge's decision to jail
Luthor in the first place for seven days
and he levied a seven thousand dollar
fine against her as well before today's
news lieutenant governor Dan Patrick and
tweeted this I'm covering the seven
thousand dollar fine she had to pay and
I volunteer to be placed under house
arrest so she can go to work and feed
her kids lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
is with me now great to see you today
it's all kind of absolutely are you
surprised at how this all kind of
galvanized so much outrage against that
Judge yeah you know Harris I've been
around the media and politics a long
time and I've seen few stories catch
fire like this one and I think it's
because people understand in America
that small business owners are really
stressed right now you know everything
they have they have tied up in their
business their money in their dreams and
one that's at risk they're gonna fight
for it and so first of all this was a
story of her fight and she's been on the
front line fighting for a while on this
protecting her 18 employees who work for
her secondly so that's the big story
she's fighting the next story is this
venn full judge sending her to jail for
seven days in Dallas County while Dallas
County has been basically turning
criminals out left and right I mean
they're DEA has a standing order if you
steal anything less than $750 we won't
even arrest you so you take those two
stories together and that's caught the
imagination of the American public and
the American public sees this nationally
and we see it quite frankly in a lot of
Democrat states Democrat County's
Democrat cities where they're putting
people in jail this was not governor
Abbott putting her in jail this was
me putting her in jail or Attorney
General Ken Paxton this was a local
decision and this judge he could have
fined her $50 she broke the governor's
executive order fined he could have
fined her some minimal amount and let
her go back to work and take care of our
employees and her kids so what do you
say to those people though who were
abiding by the rules lieutenant governor
and saying that they're gonna wait for
restrictions to be lifted I mean
everybody's hurting and you're right 66%
of the economy on average is hired by
and employs workers in America they are
small businesses so they're all hurting
and I get it so do there need to be
maybe well let's first get your answer
to that yeah well first of all when I
was on Fox last week when this story
really started breaking nationally I
send in neither the governor nor myself
we don't want to send anyone to jail the
governor had originally issued executive
orders and we asked for people to follow
them we trust people to follow them and
there were some penalties if you didn't
follow those but we didn't want to put
anyone in jail this is left to local
decision so now he's rescinded that
order so that no one can be sent to jail
no we do want people to follow the
orders and as the Attorney General said
earlier today on Fox yeah there could
have been a penalty there could have
been a small fine $100 or $50.00 but now
is not the time when people are so
stressed so stressed Harris I'm a small
business owner when you lose everything
you've invested in a business and your
life dreams you may make some decisions
that you wouldn't normally make so she
broke the the governor's order but it
didn't deserve this type of retribution
from the judge and remember the main
reason he put her in jail is he demanded
she apologize to him apologize to him
and and and and this judge I think
whether it's a you know people looking
at his action from the bench on a recall
whether it's an election next year I'm
not gonna get into the politics of that
but he has really put a focus on himself
and he didn't have to act this way you
know there's something about being a
judge and my son was a long time
criminal judge and now a US Attorney my
son was a tough judge Harris but he also
knew when it was time for mercy and and
an understanding of the of a particular
case and this
deserved it right some 33 34 million
people out of work
pitching with your heart first I think
is what you're talking about lieutenant
governor but okay I was what caught my
eye was your willingness to sit on house
arrest so that this woman could go free
and that won't happen now and now some
things have changed at the very top
echelon is in terms of how you'll treat
people who break the rules you've
acknowledged that's not an option
breaking the rules but how you'll do it
differently governor of the great state
of Texas Dan Patrick good to see you
today thank you thank you Harrison she
should be out now I don't know what the
judge is waiting for she should be out
already there's no reason to Supreme
Court has said she should be released
we'll see what this judge does oh that's
interesting well we will follow that
part of the story
thank you for flagging that she should
be and we'll look thank you again
you should be out right now I think that
was more than just telling us what's
coming next I think the Lieutenant
Governor right there was also saying it
better happen now so we'll be on it
during the commercial